打開手機每個人好像都在說什麼
AI好 AI妙
好像一睜眼就可以看到這兩個字母的身影
但是當打開自己的電腦
想要學習
網路上的這些資料多到爆炸
AI的品牌 比手機的品牌選擇還要多
打開AI工具
整個界面一片白
什麼都沒有解釋清楚
火氣就先燒上來
現在真的開始使用了
永遠都只會跟AI說
這段字數再多一點
這張圖片再歡樂一點
再活潑一點
結局就是呢
AI都在回覆一些
不是你要的內容
好像在面對一個
無法掌控情緒的另一半
學AI真的好心煩啊
這是不是你的心聲呢
那麼恭喜你
你點對影片啦
歡迎來到這堂超級AI實戰課程
你的AI神隊友系列
嗨各位我是AJ
泛科學院的主持人
同時也是
Google Gemini Academy的
臺灣區認證講師
我們頻道過去幾年
都積極在分享
各種各式各樣
關於AI的知識技巧
還有各式各樣的新資訊
這一次呢
我們受到YouTube的邀請
決定製作一堂
Gemini AI實戰課程
也就是這個AI神隊友系列線上課程
在這個系列影片當中呢
我們會帶領各位
一次上手Gemini AI的各種操作
不論是提示語的撰寫
深度研究的技巧
或者是畫布功能的操作
再到當今最強的
知識整合工具
Notebook LM
這些課程內容
都是我們過去幾年經營頻道
以及線下百場教學課程
所累積出來的精華
每一集的內容
都是現在工作
天天會使用到的技巧跟手法
上完這五堂課程
你將要完全上手Gemini
從此擺脫
AI麻瓜這個稱號
重點來啦
這次的AI神隊友課程呢
同時聯名了一年一度的
YouTube Learning 專屬認證考試
當你完成了這五堂免費課程進度之後呢
你可以從影片的介紹欄位
還有影片的置頂留言
前往臺灣數位文化協會的網站
進行認證考試
當你通過考試
你會獲得一份
大中華區絕無僅有的
YouTube Learning認證證書
這將會是你未來展現
AI能力的一個重要證明
如果挑AI課程就像選影集一樣難
那我們絕對是你值得
一看再看的那個最佳作品
CP值最高的那個夢幻課程
所以無論你是學生
上班族
創作者
或者是單純想要接軌
這個AI世界的朋友
我相信這堂課程
一定能夠滿足你的需求
讓我們一起在這個AI的時代
成為走在尖端的佼佼者吧